au fait comment c'était à la plage
mouvement t'attraper d'euros le total
mondial
ah ben non on n'y est pas arrivé m'a dit
t'es pas chez toi petit monstre
mon père et mon grand-père nous parle
pratiquement plus ma mère essaie
toujours d réconcilie ton grand père
fait partie de la famille alors on doit
surtout pas renoncer compris scott on
retourne sur la lune
ils ont appelé les deux astronautes à la
rescousse je croyais que les dinosaures
étaient éteints
tu connais au moins vieille astronautes
qui refusera habite de faire partie de
la dernière mission sur la lune mais il
n'a pas pu y aller je voudrais
réconcilier ma famille et c'est de faire
quelque chose
mais j'ai touché à rien et ça réunit
alors que cet emprunt depuis toujours
ouais je sais que ça paraît fou mais je
pourrais me cacher dans la fusée est en
route pour la lune
oh mon pote la lune c'est par là
moi
j'ai coincé continuer sans moi je me
sacrifie pour le pire de la mission
merci mon pote pour pénétrer en douce
dans la fusée il faut accéder à la
plateforme de lancement
qu'est-ce que vous fabriquez là tous les
deux qui est là ton fils et sa petite
amie simone satom dames où elles sont
jérémy bontemps de la mer trop tard
moteurs seront allumés mais qu'est-ce
que vous avez fiche une porte
dans moi 2
quoi au boulot les enfants on a une
mission
objectif lui
juste copains